hi this is steve i am going to do a
video on how to learn
chinese online at link
and the first video will be on where to
find content to learn from i'm following
the model
of the other videos
the first place to find content is in
the link library
i happen to have the library open at the
intermediate
level there are a total of six levels
beginner one two intermediate one to
advanced one two and depending on which
one you click to
you will see content relevant to that
level of difficulty
um
so a few other things you can search for
content here at the library
there is an advanced search view i'm not
going to go there
here we see the import bookmarklet which
you can drag and drop to your toolbar
and that will enable you to import
uh any text from anywhere on the web it
could be an email you've received in
chinese
or a newspaper
article online and you can immediately
import it and it becomes a lesson and
you can start learning
now here we have these
different items that have been provided
by our members
this is the rating by the users
the duration of the audio all uh these
lessons have both audio and text in some
cases they have pinyin in some cases
they have video as well
um
let me see what else is there if we go
to the beginner one
shelf
we can see some beginner
lessons some of which
link has provided and in these chinese
link versions
you will find a translation into english
or really into any language because
these
lessons are paralleled in all of the 11
languages that we support at link
let me see what else is there if i go
now bear in mind that i am not studying
chinese at link
i have imported
various texts for different reasons but
i am not actively studying chinese but
if you go to the my imports area at the
bottom you will find a bunch of
suggested resources and this is another
place that i think is
very helpful
while we have a wonderful library at
link in six different levels of
difficulty
and i would certainly you can't exhaust
those resources but if you are
interested there are some wonderful
resources elsewhere that you can go to
from here like if we click on this one
here cultural interviews in chinese from
the university of texas
and all of these can be uh it can be
integrated
with with a linked learning system so
here we have
for example this person here pretty soon
her video should show up
uh while waiting for that
girl could see the
you can listen to her you can download
the audio you can look at the
traditional characters the simplified
characters the pinyin and all of this
can be studied in conjunction with link
by importing the text and and develop
and creating a lesson in link
so um
that then is sort of initial an initial
view of the library
i could show you how the maybe i'll do
that i'll show you how the quick link
feature works if i go to something like
the people's daily and i click on an
article and the article here
and i highlight the article or part of
the article whatever i want to do
i highlight that and then i simply go to
my bookmarklet
and the bookmark that will ask me just
to confirm what language i'm in and i'm
coming from chinese so then i import
that lesson
and that lesson will then slot in
however sometimes it takes longer and
here we go and then i can start
you know i can start
linking and that is what i'm going to
get to in the next
video
so
thank you for listening and
if you have any questions please let me
know